ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Kubernetes networking
is famously designed
around core principles that
can vary in implementation.
Thus, it's essential
to understand
the specific way
cluster networking works
when using GKE.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are various resources
we interact with in GKE,
so let's break this down,
starting with GKE nodes.
In GCP, these nodes
are VMs that live
within the construct of a VPC--
in other words, a private
network in the cloud.
Each GKE node gets a
private IP and connectivity
to the rest of the cluster
and the rest of the network.
At cluster creation
time, you will
need to define your first
IP range, the node range,
from which these nodes
will get their IP address.
By default, creating
a GKE cluster
will also allocate a public
IP to each node as well.
If you want to lock down your
cluster from the internet,
it's recommended
that you configure
GKE to run as a private cluster,
in which the nodes will not
receive a public IP address.
If you want to run
a private cluster
but also want to establish
outbound connections
with the internet,
you'll need to configure
a service like Cloud NAT
for egress to the internet.
The next resource we
want to review in GKE
are pods, the atomic Kubernetes
resource that encompass
our containerised application.
In Kubernetes, each pod
gets its own IP address.
In GKE, this is accomplished
via alias IP ranges.
This means that each Pod will
have an IP address unique
in the VPC and can
be natively addressed
from other clients
in the network.
When you create a
GKE cluster, you
will need to define your second
IP range, the range from which
pods will get their IP address.
Each GKE node gets a number
of IPs from this range
that it can assign to its pods.
By default, a /24 is
carved out for each node,
which is 256 IPs in total.
Pods can be scheduled
and rescheduled
on various nodes throughout
the lifecycle of the cluster.
One challenge with
this is that it
means that the IP address
that each pod gets
may change a number of times.
This brings us to
our final resource
for which we must configure
an IP range at cluster
creation, Kubernetes services.
Kubernetes services are how
clients within a cluster
can access a target set of pods
via a stable virtual IP, known
as cluster IP in Kubernetes.
At cluster creation time, we
must define a private range
for those service cluster IPs.
Client pods can
access other pods
in the cluster via a cluster IP
associated with their service.
This IP address
will remain stable,
even as the target
pods scale up and down
or shuffle across the cluster.
Hopefully, you've
gotten a good picture
of what needs to be configured
at cluster creation time.
Given that this IP
address management
can require careful planning,
GKE has introduced two features
to make this process easier.
The first feature is
Flexible Pod CIDR.
Earlier, we talked about
how each node, by default,
will get a /24 from which
they can assign IP addresses
to their Pods.
But what if we only plan on
running 30 pods on a node?
We could potentially
strand many IP addresses.
Flexible Pod CIDR allows users
to reduce the number of IPs
that nodes in a node pool are
given to assign to their pods.
For example, in Node Pool A,
each node is configured to have
a range smaller than a /24
from which they can allocate IP
addresses to their pods.
This helps users reduce
stranded IP addresses,
which is huge when trying to
plan out cluster networking.
But what do we do when we cannot
predict how many pods we may
actually need to
run in our cluster?
This is where the second
GKE feature comes into play,
discontiguous multipod CIDR.
Rather than trying to
get a single pod range
size correct at
cluster creation time,
this feature allows users
to incrementally increase
the IP range provided for pods.
For example, in this diagram, we
have a second pod range in blue
that we have added after
cluster creation for pods.
In summary, we need
to ensure we plan out
and allocate IP space for
nodes, pods, and services
when we create a GKE cluster.
GKE provides additional features
to help with this planning,
enabling users to
preserve IP addresses
and incrementally grow their
cluster's network over time.
Now that we've
covered the essentials
for setting up cluster
networking in GKE,
visit the links
here to learn more.
With the concepts
discussed in this video,
we're confident
you'll be on your way
to building a GKE cluster
that suits your needs.
Stay tuned as we expand on other
GKE topics and GKE essentials.
[MUSIC PLAYING]